they're like okay  if the humans won't  listen to us  or they do listen to us and they  misinterpret us because we're so  different let's just go ahead and be the  human maybe they'll listen to their own  kind so that's when the galactic  federation started to look for  volunteers hey beautiful beings of  higher frequencies do you want to go on  an adventure of a lifetime  it's going to be really fun and it was  really tough to find volunteers from the  galactic federation as you could imagine  why would we leave all of this and go  down there when i reference starseeds it  means that your soul is not originally  from the lower dimensions it's not  originally from planet earth it's  actually from much higher dimensions and  you came to incarnate and volunteered to  be here as a human the problem that  happens what percentage of people are  volunteers then it's hard to say i would  say between 10 to 20 percent